hey I'm Priyanka and today I'm going to
give you some tips on how to prepare for
your product manager interview as with
all interviews it's important to prepare
in advance depending on the company
industry and the level that you're
applying for you will be asked to
demonstrate your knowledge and
experience in one or more of the
following subjects
product strategy
besides showing that you can
successfully deliver a product from
design to development to launch it is
important to also show the interviewers
that you can think big and create a
winning strategy free product that lays
the path for how you will achieve this
vision for your product there are a lot
of people that can go build a feature
but there are a limited number of people
that can really think what is the next
Generation product or how can I really
disrupt this Market that sort of
strategic long-term mindset is very
valued by employers as always practice
product strategy questions structure
your thought process and also how you
will present this answer to the
interviewer
product design this is one of my
favorite topics when answering interview
questions about product design don't
make the mistake of rushing to describe
a whole list of features instead start
by thinking about your user and
demonstrating that you understand that
the design process always starts with a
strong understanding of the user's
context and their needs and wants ask
what the success criteria would be for
this product once you have assessed this
you can prioritize the most important
user problems and come up with a list of
product features or solutions for them
to do well in the interview and go to
that next round you are typically
expected to present at least a few
must-have features some features that
solve the users need in a unique way so
bring your best creative skills to this
question and you will do well
execution
let's think about product execution
questions prepare to answer these types
of questions by thinking how did you
overcome disagreements or challenges or
hurdles in taking the products from
concept to finish your hiring manager
will want to know how you assess the
success of products once they launch be
prepared to dig into both broad criteria
like free of defects or meets customer
needs but also some specific metrics
that you would use to evaluate the
success of a product like customer
adoption retention or customer
satisfaction scores
prioritization
a great PM needs to know how to say no
to many different ideas in order to say
yes to the few really good ones show
your interviewers that you can
prioritize and navigate trade-offs by
giving solid examples from your own
experience was there a time when you
chose to focus on customer retention
over Market expansion for example and
why demonstrate how you use data to make
sound prioritization decisions you can
choose from many different
prioritization methods for example one
method that I like to use is Impact
versus effort where you can organize
your products and features to see which
ones Drive the most impact or value for
your customer compared to the effort
it's going to take and remember no
matter which prioritization method you
use you must tie it back to the product
strategy goals and success criteria
Market estimation
you will sometimes be asked to estimate
the size of a market in product
management interviews because product
managers in real life often need to know
what is the total addressable Market to
prepare for this I recommend first
creating a cheat sheet that covers key
numbers such as global population or
population of the world with internet
and so on next decide whether you will
use a top down or a bottom-up approach
to solving these questions think about
the constraints they could be on the
supply side or the demand side or both
make sure to share with your interviewer
your approach your thought process and
the formula that you plan to use for
estimation before you share your final
answer with the interviewer don't forget
to do a reality check on your answer and
revise it if needed remember product
managers are not expected to be perfect
but we do need to be able to catch our
mistakes and fix them and that's a skill
you can demonstrate to the interviewer
communication and consensus building
product management is a team sport and
your success depends on many other teams
and people
share with the interviewer how you work
with them on decisions such as maybe a
product launch date or what should go on
the roadmap or what should we include in
the next release if you want to give
some structure to these questions you
can use the star method or situation
task action and result when you answer
any of these behavioral PM interview
questions
I suggest you keep your answers
structured and concise
there you go those are my tips I hope
this will help you feel more confident
and prepared going into your product
management interview
[Music]